pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de l'étoile à la concorde la foule
parisienne a clamé l'armée française
rarement une foule aussi nombreuse ne
s'étaient rassemblées pour assister à la
traditionnelle revue militaire du 14
juillet
[Musique]
mais pas
onze mille hommes 546 engins blindés et
motorisé devaient défiler devant le
général de gaulle contours et les
membres du gouvernement et pour la
première fois une place dans le défilé
était réservée aux engins téléguidés
français sortent d'obus volant capable
de transporter une charge d'explosif
éventuellement atomique
premier signe visible d'un
renouvellement de la force française
mise au rythme des moyens modernes
[Musique]
en donne l'ordre les unités
traditionnelles terminé le défilé et les
acclamations qui les saluer avait un
sens
comme elle exprimait un voeu celui de
l'unité du pays et celui de la paix
recherchée et bientôt espérons le
retrouver
le nom de lénine écrit dans le ciel en
lettres fait de chasseurs à réaction a
marqué le début de la grandiose fête
aérienne au cours de laquelle le
gouvernement soviétique a présenté aux
moscovites enthousiaste sa nouvelle
flotte aérienne
les personnalités parmi lesquels on
reconnaissait monsieur khrouchtchev au
milieu de ses ministres et les membres
du corps diplomatique au grand complet
ont assisté au défilé de plus de 300
appareils dont une cinquantaine de type
encore jamais aperçu par les
observateurs occidentaux
qu'il s'agisse de chasseurs des collants
temps chandelle pour disparaître presque
instantanément dans les nuages d'avions
gros porteurs à turbopropulsion ou à
réaction transportant des engins
téléguidés de grandes dimensions ou de
bombardier les ga tuyères capable de
vitesse supersonique
c'est tout un arsenal nouveau qui devait
être une révélation
il est évident a pu déclarer un expert
américain que l'urss à moderniser tous
ces types d'avions il nous faudra deux
ans pour rattraper notre retard
c'est ce qui a conduit le gouvernement
de monsieur kennedy a réévalué ses
besoins militaires et en particulier a
fixé à 700 le nombre des bombardiers
b-52 indispensable pour fournir la
puissance de bombardements nécessaires
au cours des années à venir
[Musique]
dans la baie du vieux-port de garrett la
flotte italienne a reçu la visite du
président de la république monsieur gros
qui venus célébrer le 100e anniversaire
de la marine nationale dont la création
fut décrétée en 1861 lors de la prise de
la ville
dernier bastion du royaume de naples
[Musique]
en bon ordre les belles unités de cette
flotte composée surtout de croiseurs
légers et de destroyers ont salué le
passage du bâtiment qui portait le chef
de l'état
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
tous ces bâtiments aux lignes modernes
n'effaceront tout de même pas cette
vision d'un autre âge le navire école
des cadets un merveilleux voiliers où
les lignes deux gabiers le long des
verbes rappelait un temps où la terre
était aux yeux de la pérouse et du
capitaine cook infiniment plus vaste qu
aujourd'hui
parce que dans le même temps londres a
fait un accueil chaleureux au soviétique
iouri gagarine le premier homme du
cosmos
tout le long de la route qui l'emmenait
de amer smith à l'ambassade soviétique
des milliers de londoniens ont acclamé
le voyageur de l'espace
il devait être reçu par le chef du
gouvernement monsieur macmillan et
également par la reine elizabeth
ces seize siècles d'histoire convient de
célébrer à ligugé et que résume en plein
poitou l'abbaye qu'on dit le plus ancien
monastère d'occident c'est là qu'au 4ème
siècle
vint s'établir en ermite le grand saint
martin pour y fonder ensuite la première
communauté religieuse des fouilles
entreprises récemment ont découvert les
restes des premiers établissements qui
raconte l'histoire de cette abbaye créé
au dessus de l'ermitage du sein le plus
populaire des gaules avec les pavages du
7e siècle avec les fenêtres jumelées du
même temps sauf quelques entracte
l'abbaye de ligugé est resté
jusqu'aujourd'hui fidèle à sa mission à
travers les restaurations comme à
travers les avatars de l'histoire elle a
continué à vivre selon la règle que lui
avaient tracé son fondateur
aujourd'hui comme voici seize siècles
des moines se livrent ici aux travaux et
aux recherches qui sont la gloire et la
vie de leurs travaux qui font de chacun
tour à tour des épuise signé en corvée
de patates et des jardiniers qui savent
allier la beauté des parterres au
rendement du potager
[Musique]
ce qui fait aussi des érudits dont l'un
à l'aide d'une bibliothèque qui compte
parmi les plus copieuse et les plus
variés élabore la soutenance d'une thèse
théologique et dont l'autre approfondie
un chapitre de sciences ou d'histoire
l'étude fait bon ménage avec le travail
manuel
même à ces recherches certains mails
technique et travaux artistiques
l'oeuvre des anciens et mayer a trouvé
ici des continuateurs
[Musique]
et les journées depuis 16 cents ans se
suit mêlant les labeur quotidien mail
entacheront et ce avant sous le voile
permanent d'une prière ici des moines
priait au 4e siècle de notre ère à la
même place d'autres moines en 1961
travail est pris
une leçon d'éternité
tout le monde attendait l'offensive de
charlie gaulle dans la grande étape des
pyrénées superbagnères pour mélange de
la montagne avait perdu ses ailes dans
le brouillard s'était régional marcel
kaki s'échapper attaque seul le
tourmalet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non celle qu'elle y passe des tâches et
le col du tourmalet
[Applaudissements]
taye est toujours en tête dans
l'ascension du deuxième grand col de
l'étape l'aubisque qu'il franchit devant
un autre régional le 115 bus tôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
desriac et les bus tôt un petit groupe
de coureurs dont le belge pauwels numéro
même la chasse
à pau victoire du belge toys
[Musique]
la 21e et dernière étape du tour de
france ramène les rescapés à paris
jacques anquetil qui veut terminer en
beauté s'est échappé en compagnie de
quelques coureurs
[Applaudissements]
à l'arrivée au parc des princes anquetil
lance cazals victoire de cazala l'étape
victoire d'un style victoire complète
des français qui cette année était
vraiment les plus forts
comme chaque année à la saint firmin la
feria de pampelune donne aux jeunes
espagnols l'occasion d'éprouver leur
courage clowns des réjouissances
populaires ans l'âge les taureaux dans
la rue les uns poursuivant les autres
taureaux et jeunes gens arrivent dans
l'arène où ils vont s'affronter
le jeu consiste à éviter les charges des
bêtes curieuses les cornes sont en
boulet mais le jeu à ces risques
malheur aux maladroit
pendant que la reine se vident des
courageux essaie de détourner les
taureaux acharné sur la victime
[Applaudissements]
un seul blessé grave les autres avaient
sans doute la protection de saint firmin
[Musique]